[Applause]
they arrived from many parts of the
capital manila hopeful and defiant
more than 700 000 supporters showed up
at ayala avenue
for decades it's been a place for
hosting large gatherings that often lead
to turning points in this nation's
history
as the leader of the opposition vice
president leni robredo started her
campaign
with meager resources
[Applause]
but her unique messaging based on what
she calls radical love quickly changed
the electoral landscape which for
decades had been about big money and
patronage politics
her grassroots campaign has galvanized
support from nearly all sectors of
society particularly young people they
are here young people they are putting
everything on the line for this campaign
they are sacrificing their time just so
they would see a better future under
president leni robredo
young people here tell us this is more
than just a regular campaign their
participation they say is an act of
defiance after years of president
rodrigo duterte's restrictive policies
and also a major pushback against the
possible return of the marcuses to the
presidency
it has been a tough fight from the start
between two very different candidates
robredo is a widow and a human rights
lawyer while her political rival
bongbong marcus jr is the son of the
late president ferdinand marcos was
ousted in a popular revolution in 1986
the marcus name has long been synonymous
with decadence and abuse of power
but bongbong has been leading opinion
polls here for months though many
experts say they may no longer reflect
the realities on the ground because from
house to house campaigns to flash mobs
to so-called volunteer truth armies
fighting this information
many say robredo's campaign has become a
people's movement
[Music]
and on monday filipinos will decide
whether all this will have been enough
for robredo to win an election that is
seen as the most consequential in recent
history alindogan al jazeera manila